están jugando el todo por la paz
continúan los esfuerzos para conocer la
verdad de la guerra en colombia y el
miércoles vivió un día histórico
rodrigo londoño alias timochenko ex jefe
de la guerrilla de las farc y salvatore
mancuso ex jefe de los paramilitares de
las autodefensas unidas de colombia
reconocieron responsabilidades y
pidieron juntos perdón al país pues yo
no no tengo problema en seguirlo
reiterando y dice que eso va a tocar
hasta el último día de la existencia
seguir pidiendo perdón
mancuso quien está preso en una cárcel
de eeuu ha pedido ser aceptado en el
tribunal especial está a la espera de
ser trasladado a colombia donde le
señalan de coordinar más de un centenar
de masacres mancuso habló de la
responsabilidad del estado en las
muertes de líderes de izquierda y
sindicalistas la upe no fue exterminada
por pasado putin es su gran victimario
fue ley colombiana la comisión de la
verdad forma parte del sistema integral
para la paz junto a la justicia especial
para la paz y la unidad de búsqueda de
personas dadas por desaparecidas
surgió tras los acuerdos de paz entre el
estado y las farc en 2016
ante la comisión ya han comparecido tres
ex presidentes y ha juntado a víctimas y
victimarios en un conflicto de más de
medio siglo que ha causado más de 9
millones de víctimas quien dio la orden
tiene fueron esos políticos que todavía
están en línea delgadita pero no sabemos
sus nombres pese a los esfuerzos el
conflicto no termina colombia vive el
auge de las disidencias de la guerrilla
y los paramilitares además de otros
grupos armados que dejan más de 1200
asesinatos de líderes sociales y ex
combatientes desde los acuerdos de paz
de 2016